so how many people remember go fix how
many people ever use go thump to
essentially implement generics when the
rose make piles right
ok
I actually like I think I have a purple
gopher a pink gopher the blue gopher and
I have the little this guy and he's my
favorite he was one of the original ones
I remember this is about me which we're
going to quickly skip over if you want
to know ask me later anyone use cloud
foundry in here everyone heard of cloud
foundry anyone ever heard of like
rendezvous or EMS messaging systems and
financial services stuff well throw
stuff at me later continuum is a product
that EPS arif created it's a deployment
platform right that empowers IT to
seamlessly implement policy amidst agile
innovation the key point about it is
it's completely written and go nobody
cares about what we actually do maybe
you do but it was written in go which
was very interesting because coming from
Cloud Foundry which was written in Ruby
using event machine which was there's a
question on core about lion heck would
someone ever do that and I simply
responded because i like the language at
the time it was a decision for the team
and it was between go and nodejs and i
think you know people disagree I thought
it was about a 15 minute conversation
and we've never looked back what's
interesting about what we've done is is
utilizing go I made a prediction in 2012
I don't make very many predictions and I
was wrong on this one I thought that go
would dominate as a language for systems
work in IAS and orchestration and pads
and all that kind of stuff you know has
I don't know if that it still exists or
not in fact the Blake's here one of the
people of Heroku kind of the original
one along with google app engine but i
don't think i was off by much it's
amazing how many people are actually
using this language there's a go users
wiki about how many different people use
it but just knowing that you know the
undercurrents and again for me
I remember when Jabba was called oak and
I remember some of the first Java
conferences and I was lucky enough to go
to go freak on in Denver and it was
amazing not only the fact that 700 plus
people showed up but the energy the
quality of the talks and and what I
liked about it was is that it was cereal
right so you could actually see all of
the different talks it was an amazing
conference and so I do believe that this
is going to happen if it hasn't already
some people might argue with me and say
it has and this is my proof right anyone
know who's on the left Matt's a great
guy very very nice man I've got to
present that a lot of the Ruby
conferences with him early on and he
will you know give credit where credit
is due so who really uses this now this
is by no means exhaustive whatsoever but
I think it's kind of interesting
especially like on the top left with
google google was using an eternally and
for about five years I got to call
Google home I was mostly doing Java some
Python although that took me almost six
months to get code review qualified by a
22 year old saying you don't know what
you're doing which they were right
anybody know about Cooper Nettie's I
remember board I know I was never privy
to Omega but Google is really in on kind
of not only go and some of the stuff
that they might or might not talk about
this week at Google i/o but a lot of the
cool kids are up here right you know
doctor who uses doctor yeah doctor is
pretty cool stuff core OS etsy de compte
like you don't count you have to use it
Blake will be talking about that in a
second and Alex say there's so many more
but it's interesting to me how many
people are moving to it very quickly and
it's it's easy to start with without
saying we have to rewrite the whole
world right we can actually start very
small and do small pieces app Sarah
though we started that they want and
said everything is going to be and go so
we have an unfair advantage I think even
at Cloud Foundry when I was leaving
vmware I said love Ruby for development
productions challenging there's some
issues there you guys should switch to
go kind of left and I think they're
switching everything over to that as we
speak so why go for me you know it was a
decision that I put forth to the team
I've been using it since I might get
this wrong point five six is that a
release by 6.5 two or so where we used
to use go fix for every release that
came out that's why i was asking the
question it's simple language and i
think as people adopt go and they stay
with go they appreciate that more so the
note that Andrew put up there that was
the one that I want to plot to the most
I don't share everyone's opinion about
generics don't care about those but i do
like something that simple him for me
what was very very interesting with go
is is that when i went back to the
language like two weeks later was a
writing in different languages actually
understood what the heck i was writing a
lot of times in other languages i can't
remember what I was even thinking when I
was writing it it takes me 20 minutes or
so just just remember what I was trying
to do
it has a good standard library and it's
getting better faster it does have the
concurrency primitives it has a
synchronous programming model which for
those who have utilized no jazz which I
was a big fan of nodejs up to a certain
size right and then when you get past
that size you almost start doing
unnatural acts to kind of manage some of
the callback sprawl and so a lot of the
know Jas fan club says oh no it's fine
for very very big things but I would
respectfully disagree garbage collection
was great but again I remember Jabba
when it was called oak I also remember
two days of my life at Google that I
will never get back in my lifetime we're
all I did was study Java GC flags and
different combinations on the service
that we were running at Google to try to
get the pauses down I'm not saying that
pauses don't exist in go but I've never
actually had to debug one whatsoever and
the reason is one of my favorite things
is they had real stacks so at gopher con
I think I threw up my very first go
program which I tested to make sure
stacks were real that they had no impact
on the heap whatsoever and it again
you'll hear me say things like unnatural
acts a lot of any one program in Java
still how many people have programming
in the past lifetime how many people
have rewritten their application to
produce less garbage so that the garbage
collector does interfere with what
they're trying to do yeah then also it
gets really hard to understand what the
heck you're trying to do and then go for
me it was very easy i just stick it on a
stack you know i mean it gets thrown
away and the escape analysis was kind of
primitive in the point five six days but
it's getting better faster a lot of
people who know me i talk about VHS
versus Betamax most people in the shrimp
i only know what Betamax is but getting
better faster something within
technologies you should always watch for
yet they're not getting better faster by
adding stuff in right there just looking
at what makes the language the best
applied language to do something a
little while ago I made a I was actually
with Matt
Stanford and I talked about the fact
that I love programming languages as
much as anyone else does but it seems as
an industry sometimes we get caught up
in the paint brushes and not the
painting itself and go is very much how
do we get stuff done right and it was
born out of some amazing talent that's
here and also the applicability of I
don't want to wait 45 minutes for my c++
binary Google to link but Stax is a big
one at least for me it's not C or C++ i
still love c still probably my favorite
language I've always hated C++ it just
does too many things that I don't
understand what's going on that's my
fault I'm sure but for me a big reason
was it wasn't those languages and it's
not java or any JVM based language a lot
of industry within the enterprise scope
is oh you can go into production if it's
on a JVM one of the really interesting
things without giving away too many
secrets but at Google when we first had
charged back come back my belief and I
could be wrong was it was implemented
because Larry was upset at how much
resources the Gmail team was using and
ninety percent of our budget on the
chargeback was just sewn memory and so
when you look at you know spin up time
and then how much memory you know it
takes to run a java application even a
long living one versus something like go
it's a pretty big deal and it's not Ruby
Python or nodejs how many people
actually use go day to day how many
people came from the C C++ job land how
many came from Ruby Python things like
that's pretty interesting earlier on I
would have bet and Rob can yell at me if
God was wrong that the assumption was
most people becoming from C++ but
earlier on I think more people are
coming from the scripting side but it
seems to have balanced out which is
pretty interesting so why go it up Sarah
for me you know go is the best choice
for distribute systems you know you may
or may not want to do it for front-end
stuff you may or may not want to do it
for mobile although I would imagine with
the Android announcements that are
coming and some fun stuff that I would
imagine at Google i/o that will change
one of the things that we do internally
it up stair is we make our whole system
testable by every component just being a
go routine so we can actually do not
necessarily unit testing but kind of
functional testing with multiple
components that never actually have you
know an OS exact type of a path right we
just spin them up as go routines within
the same space now we do lots of black
box testing where they're actually
physically different components
different network addresses but that's
kind of a pretty good one it's a good
core language it's great ish performance
if you're coming from Ruby Python it's
great with a ! if you're coming from see
it's there's a couple things that or
Java to be honest maybe there's some
things that would like to get faster but
I have the utmost confidence that we'll
get where we need to go for me it's easy
to hire talent because it's easy
understanding grot me I don't want
someone who has go experience now I
might change that right I'm looking at
you know pretty vague Guardians here but
earlier on one of the decisions we have
to make was is it going to be painful
for us to spend people up who have never
programmed and go I think everyone has a
different version of the world but for
us it's about two weeks to kind of get
your first medium-sized thing in another
two to three four weeks a lot of the
upstairs teams here still disagree or
agree to get pretty good at it right
it's not a complex language to
understand if you have good basic
architectural decision-making in other
languages it transfers very easily to go
good standard library support again that
Betamax comment getting better faster
and this is the one that I think really
has sold me after the
act which is the tooling I do love the
core language I like things that are
simple and they apply they're not just
theoretical Haskell okay well no offense
those languages they make me think
different but I don't a program them
every day but the tooling is amazing and
it's become a critical path within eps
air all of the tools the go vet go fump
go test- trace please please please use
minus race on all your tests in your CI
systems it is very very good and they're
investing for example the static
analysis thing I think our engineering
Lee just sent out something about a week
ago about that it and I still have it on
my to-do list to read but the static
analysis tool is pretty cool think does
both pointer and type based analysis
which is pretty slick inside of Google
there's a lot of the original tooling
that showed up and go especially around
p prof and things but the team go like
team is really kind of taking it further
and probably introducing other things as
well so how do you build like a cloud OS
at least for us right you need a
messaging system i'm a messaging guy so
you might say no you don't i'm always
going to say yes you do you need to
serve a scheduling system and
orchestrator for us a policy engine
right all of those cool things with
docker it's really cool when you can do
it and it's not as cool when everybody
can do it because you want to say well
wait a minute I don't want this guy to
do it or this girls do it and one of the
things that we were looking at and
starting up Sarah was policy so we have
a pretty massive investment in a what we
think is a pretty select distributed
policy system isolation which is being
dominated right now by dr. me and Steve
haired at VMware used to argue
hypervisors were too heavy and they'll
never actually keep living on I probably
wrong about that but anyone who knows
steve is an amazing guys fun to have
debates with and at least for us
semantically aware communications and we
we do all this transparently what that
means is it's not about me or you
running inside of a system it's not even
about the fact that we can talk to each
other it's actually how we're talking to
each other at two p.m. on a tuesday and
does that actually look normal and can
we do that totally transparently weather
no code changes whatsoever in your
database of choice or your application
workload language of choice so I built a
high-performance messaging system I
built in Ruby at first does 150,000
messages a second right now it's greater
than 5 million messages second John
who's in the audience from the upstair
team was like that's great but if you
run it with the race detector so I was
one of the first guinea pigs that when I
ran it it failed horribly but it is
clean now and it's totally secure we
have a distributed scheduling system so
akin to mostly probably owe Meghan which
is the only true parallel distributed
scheduler I know of but things like
Diego out of the cloud foundry projects
Cooper Nettie's from google and of
course May sews an Orchestrator you know
I think looking at chef which is what we
use internally for staging some of the
the systems the server was kind of big
and so with go it was not that big of a
deal for us to just aren't right our own
lightweight server and the guy that
wrote that is actually back here to
who's our lead architect for the system
both vSphere and OpenStack api's are
there the policy engine again we wrote a
new policy language I should have used
Rob's thing but I didn't did a low-level
lecturer and stuff isolation with secure
print or networking the secret container
work we're probably going to devote some
of that stuff into lib container under
the docker project and then ask me later
about all the magic to make this
medically aware of stuff to work so
where we're headed this is repeating
kind of some of the stuff Andrew said
stacks now contiguous the precise defers
more performant thank you russ Cox I
think he did a lot of that gopher con
the race detector again please please
please you who uses this by default or
CI system okay you gotta you have to fix
that for me go on Android in the Chrome
OS by the native client and least one of
my favorite that I think Russ put in for
me I was in a lot of protocol buffer
stuff and I was doing hash maps maps
inside of go need a string they can't
use a bite slice and so going from a
bike slice to a string was a
and I think Brad and I talked about that
one time at waterbar and Russ magically
fixed it it's just for me that's cool
stuff so I'm rewriting some of these
things now for take advantage of that
well I go for me it's simple and I think
for the team it's simple I think a lot
of people in here it's a simple language
great ecosystem is getting better faster
for us we've been heads down most people
don't know about us say they might know
about a lot of the people that work
there it's time for us to give back so
stay tuned we're and start open sourcing
a lot of the stuff we've been doing into
the community where we think it's
valuable and helpful and so we're
excited about how we're going to go
about that this summer thank you I've
got time for a couple of questions
before the next giveaway any questions
yes the race
how many data races have I found John
how many were originally in the first
pass that you did ok it was a lot it
took me one of the things is I'm not
very good any more at any of this stuff
but my ego thinks I am so i stayed up
till about 4am and fix them all so I
could come in the next morning at 12
John it was working but ever since then
you know those race flags are on all our
CI stuff you know so that all the
automated CI tests all those raise flags
and that's why I encourage everyone to
do especially on something that you
think is foundational and structurally
you know a piece of your core
infrastructure make sure it passes the
race detector any others are you guys
got to have one good one for me all
right thank you thank you